[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the journalist
and author Rachel shabby and the times
home Affairs editor Matt dathan they'll
be with us here in Downing street from
now until just before midnight so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
and as you might imagine there's really
only one story in town
leading with Liz truss's resignation the
eye has the headline gone in 44 days
the guardian describes today's events as
The Bitter End
the Metro is utterly scathing calling
mistrust the worst PM we've ever had
The Mirror Has one simple demand general
election now
the financial times points out that the
government's economic recovery plan is
still in flux
the Sun that looks at the possibility of
Boris Johnson making a comeback to
number 10.
Telegraph has Mr Johnson touting his
credentials as well
the times also leads with rumors of a
possible Johnson return
the express dares to dream asking he
couldn't could he
the male says a contest between Mr
Johnson and his former Chancellor Rishi
sunak would represent a fight for the
soul of the Tories
and the Stars mockery of Liz truss comes
to a head a lettuce head actually as
they Proclaim lettuce rejoice
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Rachel shabby and Matt dathan welcome to
both of you let's start with the eye
gone in 44 days uh Rachel take us into
to this story did you think that we
would be here discussing this in Downing
Street tonight
I did not think that we would be here so
soon and gone in 44 days is certainly
the title of any film that might be made
about this period
um but the paper does go on to note that
she very very quickly lost the
confidence of her cabinet of her party
and of her country which I think is an
accurate reflection but I think we need
to pan back a little bit because yes
this has thrown us into Political
turmoil and political crisis but when
you're looking at a series of repeated
turmoils and political crisis as we have
seen and it's always the conservatives
that are there at the scene of the
political crime holding a Smoking Gun
then at some point we have to
acknowledge that the crisis and the
turmoil is the conservatives and they're
being in government and refusing to back
down is throwing the entire country into
turmoil and into crisis and that's why
you're seeing not just uh political
opponents calling for a general election
section which you might expect but
you're also seeing conservative
backbenches brief
um not only for a general election well
what they're saying off the Record is
that the conservatives need a time in
opposition to regroup if we have
conservative back benches saying that
that should tell us the severity of the
nature of the conservative total
breakdown that we're witnessing at the
moment
well I mean the iPhone page really sort
of lays bare the human kind of cost to
list just doesn't it you know 40 days 44
days which is uh shorter than the
leadership election over the summer that
we had for it to elect her uh it really
sort of brings home just how short her
spell has been and let's remember 10 of
those days were during the morning
period where she didn't really have
anything to do so let's just think what
it would have been if the queen hadn't
died it would be even shorter you would
presume um I mean only this time last
week was equal 10 was still the
chancellor soella Bravo was still the
Home Secretary and less than a week on
we're facing our third or possibly
second prime minister Boris Johnson
manages it um within uh within a
fortnight of that disastrous um well
they've been in fortnite becoming
Chancellor and what do you make of the
fact that it seems that the rules have
been changed because she should have had
that 12 months period of of Grace where
a new leader is is safe really well yeah
I mean technically she should have been
but um imagine going on for the next 12
months I mean talking to Tory MPS they
couldn't imagine even getting through to
the October the 31st deadline of the
fiscal statement without uh moving
against her um and reality struck didn't
it and growing Brady uh took soundings
from the party he he still hasn't
revealed how many letters he receives he
probably will never do that but some
were speculating that he'd received more
than half of Tory MPS submitting letters
of no confidence so I think he only had
one choice and that was to well I mean
he was actually Liz truss who I think
called him in this morning uh for for
that emergency talk and when she decided
to resign but I think it was only a
matter of time before he'd have marched
in himself let's move on to the guardian
at Rachel and their headline the The
Bitter End and would you say that it has
been a bit to ending
oh it hasn't ended yet has it I mean
it's ended for this trip but it hasn't
for the country and that's the point we
are still stuck in this situation where
we're lurching from one crisis to
another as you've just said very short
period of time that we've had to
experience one after the other of
conservative leaders um being ushered
into the Premiership and voiced it upon
us without an election and pretending
that that's okay it's not okay it's not
normal none of this is normal and it's
still very much bitter and it's not the
end it's a continuing reality for the
rest of the country that as we've talked
about constantly is in the middle of a
cost of living crisis and is you know
beyond despair just craving a bit of
certainty a bit of economic stability so
people can just get on with their lives
and that's not being allowed to them
because of this conservative government
Matt the Metro describes her as the
worst PM ever do you think that is
really how she's going to go down in in
political history I would have thought
so yes you can't really argue against
that I can't really think of anyone who
was worse than her
at least in modern history I mean we
thought when Theresa May had gone she
would be the worst prime minister in
living history but now it's um I mean
she nearly Boris Johnson only just
lasted outlasted her this trust only 44
days you can't really point to anything
she's achieved apart from bringing in
the energy price guarantee which which
was then watered down so I don't really
think there's anything that she can
claim to be a legacy the mirror calling
for a general election
well I think what the mirror is doing
and again it's not just the political
opposition that is doing that because to
a certain extent of course they would
they're very much in the lead in the
polls right now
but what they've recognized is actually
that is the public mood we've got a
yougov poll a snap poll that showed
two-thirds of the population we'd like a
general election certainly uh once the
the conservatives have decided on a
leader it's obvious anyone can see that
this is not tenable everybody knows it
we all know it the public certainly
knows it the political editors and
Proprietors of newspapers that carrying
on as normal and talking about the
runners and riders for this leadership
election they know it the conservatives
certainly know it the mirror is purely
stating that blindingly obvious fact
that this democratically cannot go on
the public are well aware of that and
will be furious if they have yet another
conservative leader foisted upon them in
this way
just finally we've got time to explore
the lettuce theme that the star
insisting on continuing um I think we
can bring that up we've got um
I think that's supposed to be Liz trust
there with the lettuce Rejoice 60p
letters from Tesco seven days ago uh
given a live webcam by The Daily Star
and which was going to last the longest
and it's the lettuce remarkably it's
starting to wilt though I think
behind us and if not him then who we're
going to be discussing all of that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview here in Downing Street still
with me Rachel shabby and Matt dathan
now let's move on in this section we're
going to have a look at the the times
um and this is a name that's come back
into the frame that that certain people
don't even whisper but the rumors are
that Boris Johnson could make a comeback
at
yes well I think uh he's weighing up how
much support he's got tonight he's still
in the Caribbean we're told due to fly
back possibly as early as tomorrow but
he's certainly taking soundings and uh
and letting a lot of his supporters in
Parliament and activists and donors uh
certainly try and gather as much support
as possible before I think deciding
probably tomorrow night or Saturday
whether he'll stand we hear that Jacob
Reese Morgan is going to be become The
Unofficial sort of campaign boss
tomorrow and I think he'll only stand if
he's if he's very sure that he's got the
100 MPS he'll needed because it'll be
humiliating for him if he goes for it
and then he doesn't get it what do you
think his chances are Rachel I just
think it's absurd that we're even
talking about it I mean just a few
minutes ago Beth Rigby was here
explaining some of the reasons why he
was forced to resign partygate uh tanked
in the polls the conservatives were not
doing well even before Liz trust because
of the approval ratings over party gay
and more losing the confidence of his
own cabinet that series of resignations
forced to resign by his party and and I
believe still being investigated over
allegedly lying to Parliament right so
the idea that the conservatives were
trying to rehabilitate someone like that
just shows you how utterly desperate
they are even to countenance such a
possibility it's the same story they're
covering also in the sun I mean he does
have that um he did have that incredible
mandate from the people and what the
conservatives will want now is somebody
who can win an election yes and the
supporters are making the argument in
favor of him by saying he's the only
candidate who has the Mandate that
wouldn't that they can avoid a general
election because they can say well he
had the Mandate from 2019 he can pick
that up and so we won't have to call
another general election and then he
also has the ability to win a general
election as he did in 2019. that's what
they're using to to argue in favor of
him but as you said he does face a
privileges committee inquiry which could
boot him out of parliament which would
be quite it would be even more
historical than tonight but if you had a
serving prime minister suspended yeah
100 but also it's just playing people
for fools isn't it I mean people
watching this are gonna think absolutely
Jolly well not are you going to like
this what are you having a laugh it's
absolutely absurd this is like having
you know the conservative party is like
one of those malfunctioning robots on a
TV show with like bits of metal flying
off and their heads swiveling around on
a on a wire and it's just completely
malfunctioning but saying it's okay it's
okay it's clearly not okay the party is
falling apart is is doing it in
government it needs to go the end this
is not complicated let's just run
through the runners and Riders there via
the metro map
yes Metro has a wider array of
candidates and just the sort of the
three main favorites at the moment is
Rishi sunak Penny Morton and Boris
Johnson they also quote suela bravaman
possibly eyeing another leadership bid
and Kenny badanok but realistically I
mean I was talking to a lot of the
right-wing tutorial MPS as across the
party today and they admit themselves
that because the threshold is so high
100 they don't see any right-wing
candidate whether it be pretty Patel
Sarah Brotherman getting through and so
they're sort of some of them actually
think has been a stitch up to stop a
right-wing candidate getting through so
they've sort of resigned to backing
Boris if he stands but isn't the problem
they've got now is that whoever whoever
is Anointed leader in whatever way and
however quickly they're actually not
going to be able to unite this party
that is in complete turmoil so even if
we say well constitutionally what are
the mechanisms for getting rid of
government they're not going to vote
themselves out it might just be the case
that they are not able to manage that
any leader who comes in is not able to
manage their own party and descends into
the sort of dysfunction that
precipitates them calling for a general
election so why not just a short circuit
that whole process and do it now Rachel
and Matt thank you very much